- Like the punch line
is for everybody here
content that actually brings
value to the end user,
game over.
This portion is like with me,
so I think this is when
you need to get selfish,
you need to ask your question.
(upbeat music)
Hiring is guessing,
firing is knowing.
Like you've gotta move fast,
that's how you get shit done,
that's when you figure shit out.
This is the television
and the television is the radio.
For 4Ds, mother fuckers.
- So my question is how do you work out
how much you should spend on
the content production side,
everything you're doing,
your personal brand,
I haven't even really
touched my personal brand,
and we're a content business ourselves
versus work on product,
generating more revenue
to fuel that beast.
- My answer to that is as much as possible
on the content side financially and time
but not to overjudge yourself
if you're not doing it, that's fine.
I don't dwell.
But just so everybody understands,
at the end of the day brand is what wins.
It always has, it always will.
It's how everybody makes a decision.
Literally you cannot
imagine how many decisions
you're making on a daily
basis solely on brand,
nothing to do with sales.
Yet everybody so overindexes on sales.
It's why,
I've been learning a lot
about the franchisee world
just 'cause the keynote I gave
and just 'cause a lot of inbound
and like when I started realizing
how much a new franchisee pays
these brokers to get somebody
it speaks to the same thing.
Instead of spending those,
some of these companies are,
when I look at that I'm like my God,
40% commission, 80% commission,
tens of thousands of dollars,
I'm like I could send a single tweet
and put 80 people into
franchisees right now.
When you build brand, you build leverage.
Vayner's a $200 million enterprise
and we don't do new business well at all.
We don't win FRPs,
we're bad at it,
we're bad at it
and it's not because
Andre or me or anything,
it's just it's not our DNA.
Our biggest clients just
give us the business
because of brand.
And by the way, when
you do personal brand,
you actually lose 20 or 30% of the action
'cause some people don't like you.
When you actually just
build a brand that's a logo,
it really gets going.
For me, I want to do personal brand.
At some level, I'm just
not driven by money enough
to always make the financial decision
over the happiness decision
but there's nothing that is
more leverageable for you
than the brand of your company
or you as individuals.
Where people get caught is they
fake it until they make it.
Where everybody gets caught
is they play somebody on the internet
that they're not in real life.
That has been the reason I made it.
So I would tell you that
this is a very simple game
of how much profit do
you want to take home
at the end of the year.
The reason I've always been able to scale
and get to everything
is because I've always made it
at the cost of my own
personal financial impact.
So you can if you're
willing to make less money
or you can if you realize
actually I don't like this,
I'm not into it,
I'm more of a product guy,
I'm more of a product gal,
I'm more into,
self awareness is imperative.
You can't imagine how little time I spend
on finance or legal.
For all I know, Mark Yudkin,
our lawyer owns this company.
He just puts things in
front of me and I just sign.
But that's why,
it's funny (mumbles),
comms and new business,
that's what I, or HR,
these are the things I micromanage more
or at least have opinions on.
I actually don't micromanage
but I have opinions
or occasionally I'll have
a dictatorship decision.
But I think you need
to first be self aware
of are you not doing it
because you don't like it
or it doesn't come natural
or are you doing it
because of whatever financial requirements
you're looking for?
Whether that means you want to take money
off the table each year in bonus
and do something in your
life, which is amazing,
I don't judge what somebody does,
or is it because you're
trying to flip your company
and trying to maximize
ebitsa for a multiple,
which is all okay, awesome.
I'm building businesses in perpetuity
and I'm playing for legacy
and I don't want to buy
anything in real life.
So think about why my advice
is always pour it back in.
If you understand, those
are my north stars.
But let me say this,
building personal or
brand for your business
is the single most
important thing in business.
It's the single most important thing.
It's number one, two,
three, four, five and six,
especially as the internet
continues to commoditize everything.
Everything will be commoditized,
everything you do can be
sold cheaper, different,
better, dadada.
It is your brand that plays in the end.
McDonald's sells a lot of
french fries every day.
They don't make the best
It matters.
You don't want to be
in the sales business.
And that's where everybody
for the most part is.
'Cause then you're just in a hamster wheel
of only as good as your last sale.
You want people coming to you.
The only way you can do
that is through brand.
What's amazing about the
way we can build brand now
is everybody here can do that
by providing value for the ecosystem
that they're trying to reach
versus making a clever commercial.
How'd you guys get here?
It's a super meta answer.
I didn't call you.
I didn't cold email you.
- We talked about that,
the execution doesn't have to be perfect
'cause the brand's so strong,
the execution of like getting the thing,
filling out the form,
sometimes it doesn't work right.
Doesn't matter.
- Doesn't matter.
The amount of dumb basic
shit that we do wrong,
it doesn't matter.
If you want something, you'll get it.
We don't want to do dumb shit
but dumb shit is always trumped
whereas other people have
to have everything perfect
because they have no brand,
they just have the luxury
of the quick moment of a sales pitch
and the lack of friction too.
- So sometimes it's just internal,
to feel that everything needs
to be perfect to get there.
- Oh, my greatest,
the singular strength,
my friend Tom Bilyeu nailed it for me,
I never thought about it,
singular strength I have, singular
is my inability to judge myself.
Harriet, you felt this right
away in our first meeting,
literally our first meeting,
Harriet runs comms now for us,
she's like, I'd like to change
the mission statement on our website,
this is like maybe the most
important thing that people,
it was 38 second meeting,
I'm like okay.
I was dying to think about what
was going through her mind.
Those are like seven month
processes at other companies.
- [Harriet] And I was just like,
you said okay and I didn't
know what to say after that.
- Yeah 'cause you come from a world,
which is most of the world,
where that literally,
people would have seven hour meetings
about one adjective.
- That was the one answer
you were not prepared for.
(crosstalk)
- And think about it,
it's like your first week in a company,
you're talking to the
overindexing face and founder
of the company,
it's a complete reversal
of what one would think.
But it's because most things don't matter
once you establish a brand.
I really think you should lean into it.
I think it will help your business.
But it takes time.
And I think the biggest
thing for a lot of you,
and obviously I'm giving an answer
that helps a lot of you
as I keep doing this,
the intent of the content is imperative.
The singular reason we win and I win
is 'cause not a single piece
of content I ever put out
has any intent to sell sneakers,
wine, 4Ds or VaynerMedia.
Not interested.
And people feel it.
What's that?
- [Male] You can't hide it.
- People call it bullshit radars
but we're animals.
A bat can sense things,
a dog can sense things.
We inherently have been sold
to for so long at this point
that of course you can
be tricked for a second
because usually you're the kind of person
that wants to dream and
not put in the work.
The reason diet pills and
quick rich schemes work
is 'cause people don't
want to put in the work.
You want to look like Nick Dio?
Eat well and work out every day.
Take off your shirt, Nick.
- It's good content, go ahead.
He did that last night as well.
- But you know what I mean?
It's crazy.
There's a trillion dollar
health and fitness industry
and the math is as basic as fuck.
Eat well, work out,
sleep.
But we don't want that.
We want to eat fucking cheeseburgers
and fucking potato chips
and get the results
and that's how I think about business.
This answer is 100% right.
We live in a world where
there's so much supply of everything we do
and it will continue to grow
because what I understood 15 years ago
was the internet was gonna be the middle
and everything was gonna be commoditized
and the only thing that
wasn't gonna be commoditized
was brand and then the
ability to execute a product
that was at least within the circumference
of the competitive set.
But this ideology of we
have the best product,
no you don't.
You think you do,
just like everybody thinks
their kids are the cutest.
Did America say that you're Miss America?
So that's how I think about stuff.
- How do you look toward growing,
'cause we live off of memberships
and those kind of things,
in a very competitive tight space?
They want me to move in
to a place where there's six other places
around the corner.
- Yeah, I mean look,
and it's fun to have some
franchisors in the building,
this has become such an
intriguing space for me.
First of all, what's really interesting is
when you're a franchisee,
I'm trying to calibrate in my mind
this half pregnant entrepreneurship DNA.
And it's not a negative.
You know what,
I'm actually never gonna
say half pregnant again,
I'm not kidding,
'cause I use it as a,
'cause I love entrepreneurs,
it's a very interesting idea
where you're in between
employee and entrepreneur.
That's why you signed up for it.
To me, the thought of being
at the mercy of the franchisor
is devastating.
I don't even have a board.
I don't have investors.
I don't know what to do
because if I think this is right,
this is why I hated school,
this is why I hate
anything that contains me.
Even like comms,
I'm like hey, I hope you know
what you're signing up for.
You'll tell me
but I have no idea what's
gonna come out of my mouth.
I think first of all,
anything the franchisor wants,
you have to be empathetic.
This is not a negative.
It's in their best interest.
And that's fine.
That's amazing, that's business.
But you have to A,
that would be the first
thing I would calibrate.
If you're my brother, I'd be like,
okay, let's first understand
that they want you to do that
because they want you to do that.
That has nothing to do with you.
You're a commodity.
Even though, it's just the truth.
It's okay.
I think that's not a negative.
That's number one.
And number two, what are you able to do
that distinguishes yourself
that still stays within the
lines of the franchisor's rules?
I don't know enough
about CrossFit's rules.
Every franchisor has different rules
of how hardcore, how loosy goosy.
They all run diff--
- [Male] They're super basic,
it's use the name,
have people trained and
so with that structure,
but I'm also looking
at rebranding obviously
so that we'd have more flexibility
and experiences we can create.
- And do they allow that?
- [Male] 100%.
Literally the requirement is use the name,
we're gonna use the name,
and it's a marketing agreement.
- [Female] It's a license, not franchise.
- [Male] It's literally
use the word CrossFit
and you have to get trained by CrossFit.
- I think that if you're talking about,
there's two separate conversations here.
One, is the location right
is just a classic supply
and demand conversation.
Is the rent worth the natural foot traffic
or the way I now think about it
which is not 1987 anymore
where you just get the traffic
because there's a Whole Foods
or a mall or what have you,
it's how much do I like
the two mile radius
of Facebook and Instagram ads against it?
That's how I think about it now.
- [Male] Well I like
that as a good metric.
- I think that's a really,
what I would do,
Tim Ferriss did something super smart
when he did the Four Hour Workweek.
I mean I heard about it 13 years ago
and to this day, I still think about it
'cause I didn't do it and I wish I,
at some level it's so smart.
And I do it with my content.
I'm doing something
incredibly interesting lately
with my content.
We call it the machine.
I'm running the same video on Instagram
with seven different
thumbnails and titles,
seeing which one overindexes
and then I'm posting it
organically on my page
and they've done much better.
I think one thing you could do
is almost run an ad on
Facebook and Instagram
on a fake gym that doesn't exist
and say coming soon
and just seeing what people
react to and be like,
and just getting a sense of,
I would almost run a fake gym
with maybe another popular brand,
whether it's Equinox or Barry's, whatever,
or Orange Theory or whatever
and run it on 15 different mile radiuses,
or if you have four options of locations
and just seeing where there's more demand.
- [Male] I love that.
- I mean for 1,000 bucks,
you can get a read on if
there's more demand than not.
- So what worked from a
operations side of things?
When did you get a, did you
get a chief operating officer?
What kind of worked?
But also what didn't work
and kind of the why aspect.
- That's a great question.
So I always overhire, always
because I'm anticipating growth
and that's how you grow.
- [Male] Overhire as in more
volume as opposed to quality?
- Well you'd like to think
that you're getting the quality
but yes, to your point,
I was like, you seem nice, you're hired.
That was literally how it
went for the first 300 people
because I was willing to fire.
And I don't like to fire.
I'm kind of like I'll
turn this bad boy around,
like that kind of DNA.
So it was a really interesting
double play on my side
which is I talk about hiring
fast and firing faster
but I also don't love firing
because I was so into being operational
and trying to fix in parallel.
I think a lot of this comes
down to knowing yourself
first of all.
So I'll give you a very
good piece of advice.
I genuinely believe this
and I've seen this everywhere.
Hiring around you
on the things that you
don't want to be doing
is unbelievably powerful.
I couldn't be more bullish on it.
If all of you right now
just truly take a step back and say,
what do I do every day that
I don't want to be doing
and hire for that,
I couldn't be more,
the reason a COO has never worked for me,
not my dad, not my
brother, not James Orsini
is 'cause I'm an operator and I love it
and I'm willing to
leave money on the table
'cause I know if I'm a CEO
I could probably generate more
top of the funnel business
but I love the challenge of operating.
It's the game.
I like it.
Oh, Rick should be there
or Susan should take that account
or we'll create this pro, I love operating
and I'm good at it.
That's why we're not vulnerable.
When you hunt,
you gotta be able to farm it.
And when you know how to operate,
that's where most entrepreneurs lose.
They can get the business
but she or he can't operate it.
So I would highly recommend
hiring around you.
So if you're thinking about COO,
are you just so overwhelmed
or are you trying to be
more physically out there?
But then if you're trying
to be physically out there,
look, nothing excites me
more for B2B businesses today
than running content ads on LinkedIn
against the employees
of the people you know
you're trying to reach.
Your business is so,
as somebody who's been in
B2C and B2B, B2B's easier.
When you know who you're
trying to reach, it's easier.
I don't know who the fuck
drinks wine or wears sneakers.
But when you know
that literally the companies
you're trying to reach,
you can run ads right now
against employees of that
on Linked In
and all you have to do is make content
that is valuable to them
instead of saying sign up now.
Instead of an infomercial,
make a B2B magazine.
It could be even not even
about your own product.
- Yeah, we've got this big,
so the reason I'm here
is we've got this big
conference coming up,
it happens every year,
American Library Association
Conference, rock and roll,
it's in DC actually in June
but we have a 20 by 30 booth
and we're talking about
taking a video team with us
but we're going to interview,
not just our customers
but other vendors in the
industry and that kind of stuff.
- Obviously you know enough
about me to know this,
the second everybody here can
be the voice of the industry
and bringing value to
everybody in the funnel,
the quicker they win.
It's what I learned with Wine Library TV.
I started that to do QVC
and within episode one,
within the episode,
intuitively I needed to become
the wine spectator, not QVC,
and it changed the course of my life
and I've done it ever since.
Guys, there are hundreds of agencies
that literally just watch my content
and get clients that we're trying to get
with the same words,
think about how much I believe in it,
it's coming out of my
own short term pockets.
I'm really giving my best shit.
What?
- [Male] Thank you.
- But think about how interesting that is.
It's a really like,
it's kind of,
not that I'm knowledgeable
enough about the bible
but I get it thrown at me,
it's quite biblical.
It's truly that.
So the greatest thing you
could do at this DC conference
besides be successful and do your thing
is to listen to the problems
that they're all facing
and put out content that addresses it
or makes fun of it.
The amount of two minute videos made
that is a skit by comedians
that make fun of library culture is zero.
Every single fucking
person in the industry
would share a video that was funny
about the 11 truths in your business.
You know what I mean?
The cliche shit.
The Dewey decimal system shit,
yeah like that.
- [Male] There's a character show that--
- If you guys did a Dewey thing,
if you dug up Dewey,
the punch line is for everybody here,
content that actually brings
value to the end user,
game over.
Back to CrossFit,
the big cliche thing I hear all the time
is like people get hurt.
If you just put out a content series,
and that might struggle with corporate,
and I have empathy for that,
but if the content series in theory
was just like how not to get hurt
and just deep knowledge
on the cliche 44 reasons
why people do,
you get overcompetitive,
you lose your form,
I don't know what the fuck,
I believe in that shit.
I put out so much content
with the hope that nobody ever hires us.
I'm not kidding
'cause enough people will.
And that's how you build
brand and sentiment
and like karma and a
whole lot of other things.
Plus, there's one thing that I always have
which is that I know that
I'm always gonna be good
at emerging trends.
I'm not scared to give away
all my social media advice
'cause I know I'm gonna be great at voice
and AR and machine
learning and block chain.
I'm the same thing just, you know?
You're welcome.
- All right, so I have
two kind of questions.
So the first one is
where I get mixed up a lot is
that we have two audiences.
So we're selling franchises
to a million dollar network investor
but then our end user, whose their client,
is a hair stylist making 50,000 a year.
So how to differentiate our company
to these different audiences
and then the second piece is we've been--
- I think one thing you can do is the logo
could focus on the end user addressors
and then the humans,
whether you or somebody else,
could focus on the franchisees.
You see where I'm going?
First of all, you or somebody
and the logo of the company
should have separate accounts.
There's a VaynerMedia
account, there's GaryVee,
there's Wine Library.
So if you think about the nature of it,
the brand can really focus on the end
and you can focus on the B2B part
with occasional reference to the end.
- [Female] Having two
distinct user accounts
or two distinct brands?
- Look, I'll be honest with you,
I'm also extremely comfortable
with the account doing both.
Some people may find it intriguing
on the back end business stuff.
It's not the end of the world.
Most of this stuff is not
about organic anyways.
It's about paid amplification.
But I think there's a natural
for you guys to have a human face, yes.
- [Female] Yeah, absolutely okay.
And then the second one is
so we've been creating content
and putting it out there
with very little success.
I don't think our competitors
are doing it great
but how do you set
benchmarks for your team
to hold them accountable?
How do you know when to fire?
If I say hey, our socials
are digital stakes now,
I could fire everybody.
- Business results.
- [Female] And we're doing good
but I don't think we're
knocking it out of the park
with digital by any means.
- So fire.
- [Female] Fire?
- Yeah, there's no benchmark,
that's a she or he decision.
What you'll learn is
it's like breaking up with a boyfriend
and then thinking two
boyfriends down the line,
eh, was I wrong about Rick?
'Cause he's been a lot
better than Stan and John.
Maybe I fucked up.
That happens
but that's the true answer.
To me, it's like, are you happy
with your business results
from the thing?
And if you're not, business results,
not how many likes or shares
or followers, business results.
And if you're not,
that's attributable to that,
you break up with Rick and you just hope
that that was right.
- [Female] Yeah.
I haven't seen anyone in
my space do it really well
so it's like--
- As well trying to get
the one million dollar
people into the funnel
or as well on the end user?
- [Female] I would say both, both.
We're all, in franchising,
really dependent on brokers,
especially at that million
dollar investment level
versus a CrossFit or a fitness.
The owner operator models
of 100, 200,000 to invest
are pretty easy organically
but that million dollar investor
it's been a little bit harder
to tap into organically.
- It makes sense
because I think to get that person
you need to be making a show
about the whole concept of franchisees,
not about your specific content.
You see where I'm going?
You need to become the
back of Inc. Magazine,
you know what I mean?
- [Female] We're in it this year.
- But you need to become Inc.
This is where I keep going into that,
you need to interview 365 days a year
somebody who's successfully
run a franchise
to inspire the people who listen to that
to then get into the potential funnel
of considering you.
- [Female] And see, that's where
I think those two audiences
come back in,
that's not relevant to the salon person--
- It's not.
And so you make that
and you run that on LinkedIn
and then on Instagram,
you see what I mean?
- [Female] Mine is stay with the brand,
move on to a new brand idea.
So we have a brand that, it's called Cibu,
it's our private label, hair care,
it does have it's own website.
It has no brand awareness.
We have links from that platform
onto our other salon sites.
So we do a little business online
and a little bit more
now that everybody understands
what a CTA is in email
on our team.
But the issue is
could we create something
bigger and better
that actually solves to a bigger purpose,
not just selling Cibu,
but it allows indie brands
to have a bigger site to be
able to launch their brands.
- As long as you understand
how big of an ambition
the sentence that just
came out of your mouth is.
What you just said in that sentence
is usually a 50 million to 100
million dollar funded startup
with deep two-way marketplace DNA.
The answer is you could but there's,
people sometimes ask me,
hey Gary, God you were so early
at all these tech
companies, this and that,
why don't you have an app,
why don't you have a company?
I'm like because I don't want to
'cause I don't think it's my strength.
I don't think I'm the founder
of Uber or Facebook or Twitter.
You're also talking about
at a time where Shopify and Amazon
are gonna grow at scale.
So for you to create a
third party marketplace,
an infrastructure to be a WordPress,
you're going into shark territory,
which you could win within a small niche
but you have to make sure
that you guys have the DNA to actually,
as long as you notice,
I'm jumping in because I want to make sure
you realize that that's not,
everything so far has been like
a pass away comment meaning,
not to undermine it,
it's like it's doable.
Yours is doable
but you're gonna build a
billion dollar business,
that's a real big thing.
And I think people
throw around this theory
very nonchalantly in the business world.
Every day, I get a,
oh, we're gonna be a marketplace,
I'm like pttth,
there's like six marketplaces.
Yahoo lost being a marketplace.
So yes, I just want to make
sure that you understand,
I'm giving you a reaction
to make sure you understand
how grand that is.
- [Female] Yes, I do, I do.
I've actually started a website before
and it's monstrous in terms of the money
and the time and the people--
- At this time
when it's never gonna be
easier or less friction
to do short term sales
through the Shopify and Amazon ecosystem
it's not about,
it's not the macro thesis,
it's the thesis at this moment
in the emergence of those
two specific platforms
that gives me just pause to think about it
but go ahead.
- [Female] Yeah.
I mean my worry is if we
stay with what we're doing,
at some point I don't know how relevant
what we're doing today
on ecomm is gonna be.
- Speak to me about that.
When you say,
I just want to make sure
I'm following along,
you mean how relevant
that one brand will be?
- [Female] Yes.
- So look, I mean it's not
a very complicated thing.
To your point,
you just have to understand
if you're looking to become
a platform or a product.
Are you gonna be a Smartwater
or are you gonna be,
its not Walmart but QVC, right?
They're just two very different things.
I will say this,
I believe that we're walking,
it's ironic,
I'm gonna take a little
bit of a different stance,
I think we're walking into the golden era
of the capability of
direct-to-consumer brands at scale.
You're gonna be competing
but the opportunity to have the leverage,
think about the nature of being a product.
You're always at the mercy
of your distribution.
- [Female] Yes.
- You're not going to be.
And so that's exciting.
It's now how good is the product
and how good are you at building
a brand around a product
versus how good are you
at building a platform
and building a brand about the platform?
I think that becomes the debate.
But I wouldn't run away from being a brand
because a lot more brands are coming.
I would try to,
I see the positive in DTC
more so than the negative, I really do
because the ability to compete
against everybody else's DTC
is I think more of a fair fight
than competing with the hope
that Sephora carries you.
There was major tollbooths
that kept all the margin.
The retailers have won the leverage game
over the last decade.
So I think that's the question.
I'm excited about DTC.
I just think you have to be the best,
let me rephrase,
I think the long tail of DTC
is more fruitful than the
long tail of marketplace.
- Got it.
- You see where I'm going?
- [Female] I do.
- That's my point of view on it.
And I'm spending a lot of
time in that world, a lot.
- I'd like to piggyback on that.
For us, we've got 10% of our sales.
So we've got $500 million in sales.
10% comes from product
and then 90% from service, right?
The 10% more profitable,
better margin for us.
We have a stallion on haircuttery.com.
We tried to how do we build that name
and the thought was do
you build a different site
that allows you to track more eyeballs
to sell our product off of
versus haircuttery.com?
- Or you could just,
what is the brand called?
- [Male] Cibu.
- What about building,
well we do that, that's correct
but we sell,
our concern is the 10% we sell right now,
you can buy it on Amazon,
you can buy from the
website of Paul Mitchell,
you can go to Amazon and buy,
our concern is are we gonna lose that 10%
because we just--
- You're gonna lose it if
you're not thoughtful about it.
But if your site has an
added layer of value,
like a club that creates
content or access,
I think you should
immediately start creating
a weekly, monthly, yearly special skew
only available on your world.
So if you're formulating new products,
one of the things I'm trying to push
a lot of my CPG brands
is to create a super premium version,
so like I'm literally
trying to sell $100 ketchup
that only comes out during the holidays,
you can only buy on their dot-com.
So I think what's amazing is
I think this is fun,
my natural DNA
is always to look at the
offense of a scenario
versus a defense.
Your defensive point of
view is absolutely correct.
There's far less friction buy from Amazon
when you're buying your
deodorant and your peaches
and then throw yours in.
But you actually fucking own the product.
So your ability to create a club,
so if you're buying your
stuff, you're in the club,
and I have no idea what
you want to add onto that
'cause you have,
one more time, I'm trying to remember,
so you've got this product
then you have salons, right?
- [Female] We do.
We sell 'em in salons
and then our products also sold on Amazon.
- Right and then you have your own salons?
- Mmhmm.
- Which we sell
about six million worth of this product.
- Of this product,
but the salons are yours?
- [Both] Yes.
- I mean look, in theory,
you could tell the end consumer
that they get a five percent
discount on their salon work
if they buy the product on your site.
You have all the advantages.
I'm a big fan of fucking
Amazon before it fucks you.
That's what I did with Facebook.
Facebook didn't fuck me,
I built myself off of it.
You have the leverage.
You can use Amazon to get
people into your ecosystem
and then remarket to them as the brand
by printing something on the
back of the fucking bottle
that says join Club Cibu.
So I think it's a concept of,
I don't think it's as black and white
as the convenience of the
lack of friction of shipping
or cost,
I think it's what are you
gonna do to the product
and what are you gonna
layer as bells and whistles,
added value,
that forces everybody,
I actually genuinely believe
that the smartest brands
are gonna fuck Amazon,
not the other way around,
if they're very thoughtful
to some of the stuff
I just referred to.
When you build added value
around buying it from you
at the same price, you win.
Now you can use Amazon as your
gateway drug to acquisition.
That's what I would do.
- [Female] Okay, well
thank you, appreciate that.
- [Male] Other question I had is,
we're gonna talk later on
the agenda about culture.
We have a very strong intentional culture.
We have founded business by Dennis Ratner
and he's really created that culture
which we've got a lot of
tenure in our business.
But we're projecting it out
over the next 10, 15, 20 years
from a legacy perspective,
how do we keep that culture
and how do we actually make it stronger?
So any recommendations
on how you believe
culture here, for example,
and what you're trying
to do to create a legacy
and what you'd recommend?
- You've already kind of won.
Even if there's 98%, let alone 100% truth
behind your statement, you've already won.
The ambition for legacy
already changes behavior.
I think this is a big game of firing.
I think the biggest challenge
for people that look like me
and it sounds like what you guys have
is do you have the stomach
for short term financial pain
by firing the most productive
but people that don't actually
bring value to the culture.
It's a very simple game of
like do you live your truth?
It's really easy to maintain culture.
Choose culture over money.
I really believe it.
I live it,
I watch it,
I see it in companies that I push it into
if they're an investment of mine.
I really think it's,
it's scary when something
like that is so simple
but it's like religion,
do you follow it or don't you?
And where you choose to bend
becomes the variable of
how good the culture is.
The culture's made up
of the humans that are in it at the time.
And like when there's lore,
founder Rick Thompson or Susan McGoo,
whoever's the executive of running that,
whoever runs VaynerMedia
when I go and buy Smartwater
and become the CEO,
and that's what's gonna happen.
The next chapter of this company is
I'm gonna buy something
when the world melts
and when I go run Mountain
Dew or Snickers or Puma
or whatever the fuck I buy,
I'm gonna be at the mercy
of her or his capability to
uphold what I believed in.
And so I think you make it clear.
That's why,
it's funny if you think about
America this way, right,
how we interpret the bill of rights
or the constitution
becomes obviously very intriguing,
it's what becomes our culture,
but having it is already
the starting point.
But I think it's one,
I believe culture's one big game
of do you have the ability to fire
the most productive, worst person?
I really believe in that.
- [Male] And it's not gonna be that,
it's gonna be the Jets
you're gonna buy, right?
- Yeah but the way I think I get there
is by that in between move.
I really do.
I really think,
the reason I built Vayner
and the reason it's built this way
and unique in its way
is I think I've built something that,
if I truly bought Smartwater tomorrow,
it would be a much bigger
company after four years
based on all the things we've done.
- [Female] So I'd like to get back
to the concept we were talking about
about company brand versus personal brand.
Right now, our social media content
is kind of focusing on both.
We've got our company brand
that I focus on
probably more than Arie's personal brand.
And Arie really is the
brand of the company.
So my question is my time is limited.
I only have so much to put into it.
Which one makes more sense
to put more time into?
- Which one is doing better
from your perspective?
Are you doing it yourself
on your own page at all?
- [Male] My own LinkedIn page, you mean?
- Or wherever you guys are?
- [Male] Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's correct,
off my own LinkedIn page and then off--
- You know, what is always the way,
when Harriet was like, I'm sure,
this is fun to have her in the room,
when you're in our industry, as she is,
and you look at Vayner from the outside,
people believe the vulnerability
is it's so much about me
and not enough about Vayner,
and there's real truth to that.
If you're an executive at Smartwater
and you're like, am I getting a company,
is it Gary?
These are the things
you need to think about.
At the same token,
when you kind of start peeling away
and you start realizing
this is a company that
doesn't have to win business
through RFPs and you think
about all the dollars,
you start having a really,
you have a more complicated debate.
For me, for example,
this is why I'm bringing this up,
the thing I'm probably most proud of
in the 10 years that I've run this company
and built this company
is my ability to trick the
market of how big it is.
My biggest fear
was if anybody in the big boy
and girl world of advertising
understood how big what I
was building was going to be
that they were gonna focus on it.
And I'd never competed
against multibillion dollar
international companies
starting from zero.
That's a challenge.
Because if one really understood me,
they could just throw money at it.
Literally if I was the
competitor of VaynerMedia
five years ago,
I would've literally emailed
every single person on LinkedIn
that worked here and said,
"What's your salary?
"I will pay you three times more."
And it would've been the
right business decision.
So I've purposely not
built VaynerMedia's brand
because I needed the market,
my competitors,
to underestimate it
and continue to think it's
Gary and a bunch of interns,
who is this charlatan
and this can't be real.
That was our advantage.
From the outside, it's too much about me.
But what nobody knew from the inside is
I have no clients.
I've built a scalable company.
Building up Gary, you would think,
oh shit, every client's gonna want Gary.
I don't talk to any of 'em.
So I was able to successfully
create me as a top of funnel awareness.
But then when it became a real meeting,
she or he on the other side, the CMO,
we right away, I'm not
your account person.
I could be in the backbone business.
We could have lunch once a year.
But I'm the CEO and executive of this.
I don't service your account.
You're buying VaynerMedia.
You're not buying Gary.
That comes down to how he's
running his business right now
where you guys are at scale.
So I guess those are the questions,
are you servicing the business?
Is it a vulnerability right now?
Is it small enough
where we can keep leaning in
to what is actually working?
Do you do a good job once the
customer comes in the funnel
to realize it's not him?
Or is it still him at this point?
Which is super fine too.
That's the right formula for that.
Does that make sense?
- [Male] So to the extent,
just to go that one step further,
to the extent that it isn't
me doing the servicing,
where does that fall into the?
- It is not you doing the servicing?
- [Arie] It's not.
It's very clear early in the funnel,
the conversation happens right
that it's not gonna be,
but I still do close
almost all new business.
- I get that and so did I.
Then I probably still,
I would say this,
if you are fortunate enough to have a face
that has all the right personality traits,
I'm sure Harriet's gonna continue,
I'm not looking to suppress
my people into the press.
I just don't want anybody
to know who the fuck we are.
There's strategy to it.
So I think if you still have
all the right characteristics,
I think if you're fortunate enough
to have a founder,
if she or he has good characteristics
and it's not about ego and insecurity
and all those weird things,
then you ride that personal brand
because it converts better.
A human face converts
better than a logo often.
- [Female] The struggle is also his time.
Because he's the CEO
and he's doing all these other things,
his time is extremely limited.
- That's why I created
document, not create.
- [Ari] Can I?
- Yeah you can bounce, we
can bounce, we got time.
- [Ari] So then the riff on that
or where we struggle a little bit there
is sort of in the B2B world right?
So we're a small company,
a little over 40 people,
the B2B world, some interesting parallels,
our market, since we're
looking for companies
headquartered very nearby,
is a limited market,
there's maybe 1,000 companies
that could potentially
be our clients locally.
So we engage there.
But the people that we connect to
are generally CFOs and CEOs
who care very little
about the detail of how we execute
but care a lot about the
outcomes that they get.
So I find that we struggle,
or I struggle to see the
document versus create
when I feel like a lot
of the documentation
isn't super interesting to them
and wouldn't necessarily
get them interested.
- Makes a ton of sense.
So to that point,
I agree with you,
I don't think you should document, create
which is why we created the model
around the podcast or the show.
There's two ways to go
and I think when you start inviting them,
so you're saying it's literally just like,
nothing excites me more,
and there's a couple here,
then to having a regional business
to do a show around
because then you get to host a party.
- [Female] We like parties.
- [Arie] We love parties.
- Literally, you guys should literally
have every business leader,
CEO and CFO on your show.
Once you host a party, you win.
I've said it a lot,
and maybe you've caught it in my content,
I call this the high school party role.
If you're the kid in high school
whose lucky enough that your
parents travel on weekends
and you're like a C-level popular kid,
the second you throw the
junior year party at your house
you go from a C to an
A minus in popularity
because you're letting the A
pluses make out at your house.
- [Arie] So where do we
figure out how to get,
what that good content is?
- Do a show where you interview businesses
in the Hartford area.
- [Arie] Okay.
- Literally once you
establish some macro show,
whether you call it, New
England this or Hartford that,
create a macro framework for it
and now you're emailing
literally the people you
want to do business with
saying, we're intrigued
by your leadership,
we'd love to have you on the show
versus emailing them saying,
we want your business.
- We're already doing that, not at scale--
- Scale, scale.
- [Male] And then to add
another wrinkle to it
is not only is it businesses,
it's manufacturers,
high tech manufacturers.
So it's even more niche.
- Love.
That's even better.
They don't get any fucking love.
What fucking podcast
wants them on their show?
Nobody.
No, really, this is really quite crazy.
I know you know it,
you're feeling it intuitively,
like imagine a world,
this played out extremely
for me real quick,
just to bounce around a little bit
on the PureWow and 137
side, we have podcasts.
We just launched a show
called The CMO Podcast.
I got Jim Stengel,
whose like the former CMO
of Proctor and Gamble.
He's like the legendary CMO
to all the current CMOs
'cause Proctor was Proctor.
He's the host.
And literally the CMOs of the
biggest companies in the world
are literally coming
through our door every day
to be on a show.
Imagine an hour a day,
you will get everybody to say yes
that you've been dying to
have a conversation with
about a business,
if you say come to my office
and sit with me for an hour
and I'm gonna interview
you about your leadership,
your business, your thing.
They're literally walking
into your fucking company.
And if you really have
the discipline to not sell
and say nothing, nothing,
inevitably she's gonna be on the way out
or he's on the way out, gonna say,
what do you guys do here?
Ahnanan.
Oh really?
Actually I fucking hate my people.
Why don't you call up,
I'm gonna put you in touch with
Rick Thompson who runs our--
- 100%, 100%.
- [Female] You could shoot
the shit for an hour.
- Easily.
- By the way, there's nothing easier
than to be a host of a podcast.
You ask eight basic questions.
How'd you get into this?
What's been going on?
It's super crazy.
I know, it's super obvious
and what's scary about super obvious
is how well it works
back to what I think about all the times.
The reason I put out everything
is I do not believe my ideas,
even though a lot of times they're early
and well thought out historically
are my special sauce.
My execution is my special sauce.
Right?
- 100%.
- Can I ask you a
question about the day in,
how did you scale the business so quickly?
So one of the biggest
challenges that we have right
is we've been successful.
So our marketing strategy,
we're doing a lot more digital now
but has been a lot of
we call it one to many.
So they'll book me to go
like to the Connecticut CPA Association,
a lot of just educational content,
zero about us, all about--
- But think about how
much if you film that
and put it on LinkedIn.
- We have.
We have a lot of footage.
- Yeah and that's what we're
starting to super get into.
So now the challenge we have
is like we're almost
overselling the capacity.
And it's not like McDonald's,
I just get a bigger fry later
and I generate more fries.
Getting the human capital
ahead is a challenge.
- People overthink hiring.
- [Arie] Just hire?
- It sounds scary,
I'm gonna hire a clown,
she or he's gonna suck
and I'm gonna lose the client.
I'm like but you wouldn't
have had the client.
And when you're willing to
bleed if your ambition's high,
I always feel like I'm able to fix.
- It's not the bleeding of the money,
although clearly that's
somewhat part of it.
- No, no, but notice how my
analogy wasn't the money.
- It was the clients.
- I think you're coming from a good,
I think most people
come from a good place.
- I do have a big fear around that
of breaking the brand.
We have so much good street cred.
There's that huge fear of
like fucking up that client--
- Bro, everything's fixable.
- Yeah, another at-bat, I know.
- Give 'em the money back.
Money's not actually the thing.
For me, like I'm never scared
'cause everything's fixable.
I'll give you a year free of service.
I'll fucking let your son intern here.
I'll do whatever the fuck,
everything's fixable if you have that,
this is why I talk so much about intent.
This is why I talk about lack of fear
plus the biggest mistake
a lot of people make
is they make a call for the other person.
Life's about alternatives.
If the client's happy,
the client's happy regardless
of what you're subjective
of like or qual, right?
It's hiring.
I don't overthink hiring.
I try my best, I hire.
People have so much ego in hiring.
It's just this underlining
like insecurity to be wrong.
I love when I'm wrong.
Guys, I mean this,
you don't know me well enough to like,
this is the truth,
there's a weird part of me,
I don't know if it's like,
it's probably a very flawed sick part,
I get excited sometimes when
I hire a very senior person
and like a week later I'm like, nope
and I know that for the next 18 months,
because right, 18 months,
and that's like C-suite
where you just can't scare everybody
that you're just fucking
changing it like your underwear,
you know what I mean?
But do you know what that,
that's happened to me twice.
A week in, I'm like eh, fucked it up.
And then all the extra
work I have to put in
to disguise that
and manage it and manage,
and then four months later,
the smartest people start saying,
wait a minute, I think this person sucks
and you got to manage that
and nine months later when
the next level of smart people
are like I think this person sucks
and you gotta, the game.
- So just lack of fear--
- Lack of fucking fear.
And more importantly,
no business, yeah firing.
And listen, I'm the worst.
I'm a bleeding heart like
you would not imagine.
- You have a piece of content
where you talked about sort of like,
if you can't do it,
just overpay them out.
So we're just letting
somebody go right now,
I just feel horrible,
she's got a bad situation,
she's only been with us for three months,
I was like, just give her six
months severance, whatever.
- I do it all the time, bro.
Isn't it great?
Dude, at the end of the day,
it's not about money out here.
It's about feeling good and happy
and like I understand that
my CFO's not happy with me
but that's what I need.
I fucking fire people,
give 'em a huge severance
and then I pay them on
the side for two months.
I do so much weird shit.
I always think like man,
if somebody investigated me,
they'd be like oh here's
the fucking silver bullet.
Why's he paying Rick on the side?
'Cause I'm nice.
It's like super weird.
Like nobody would ever believe me,
if you played that on 60 Minutes
of somebody trying to get me,
they'd be like impossible.
- Is it literally just your DNA?
Is there some mental pneumonic,
again this is a crazy kind of question
but it's like, you know what I mean,
'cause we have sort of similar
family backgrounds actually,
eastern European Jew,
immigrant stuff, right.
And like so we just,
first of all, being education,
education, education.
So like when I went off the lawyer track,
my parents are like oh
my God, what's happening?
- I got lucky.
That's where I got really blessed
and I feel a huge sense
of guilt and gratitude,
I can't believe my mom let
me get away with D's and F's
where everybody else
was like you're going to fucking Harvard.
Like I really hit the lotto on that one.
- But that perfection was
like almost like beat in--
- Not mine, not mine,
that's where I'm trying to create clarity.
It's why I'm so confident.
All that happened in my life
was everybody said I was
losing except my mom.
So think about that.
You've won.
That's actually the dream scenario,
the dream scenario for
disproportionate confidence
is the world tells you you fucking suck
but your mom tells you you're the best
and she's also smart enough
to not create delusion.
So when you go 0 for
four in little league,
it wasn't the sun's fault in your eye
or your coach's.
It's you suck.
So it's accountability but ugh,
she fucking crushed it.
I am a complete byproduct of,
and not only that,
I've been hot on my mom stuff lately,
my dad saved my ass big
because what I was also though
by being such a good storyteller
was I was completely full
of shit when I was 14.
I would say anything to sell anything.
I lied out of my mouth 24 hours a day.
And that's who I would've become
and that's what a lot of
people think I am at first
'cause of my showmanship
but he corrected me
'cause I got lucky again
that my dad is,
my dad thinks if you
embellish to him once,
embellish,
there were 19 people at the party.
He's like there were eight and that's it.
Three strikes you're
out, I'm not your friend.
Literally.
I don't know a single more extreme version
of somebody who's more
uncomfortable with exaggeration,
let alone lying, than my dad,
which over the course
of four or five years
in my teenage years,
scared the fuck out of me.
'Cause it started with like
dad, I sold 98 bottles.
He's like you sold six.
And then six became from
98 to 44 to 13 to six.
I'm very aware of how this all happened
and then if like it was reversed
and my dad was first
parenting me and my mom,
I would've been a completely nightmare.
I would've been insecure and full of shit.
So like I'm quite grateful.
So anyway, I'm sorry,
but I wanted to create that clarity.
That is important for you
to know that part though
and I think a lot of what you're hearing
manifests from that.
But I host the party.
- Yeah, get back to the
hosting of the party.
- And let's talk more
because you've got three seats here
if you have a question.
- I would bounce back to
part of the value of this
is confirming what we already
know and watching Arie go
crap, I know we should
be doing that, I know.
And then you get excited
and we start to hear,
you guys have it so easy.
It's like a niche within a niche.
You know the 1,000 businesses,
geographically you know where they're at.
- Yeah, because geographically
gets into branding
that I get excited about.
Like to me, I wish,
just 'cause I know how
big I can make something
'cause I'm an operator,
I'm like man,
if I had the New England business podcast,
it's game over.
Give me one year.
- The New England
Manufacturer podcast is even easier.
- Yeah.
But like yeah, that's exactly right.
- [Male] I think we've been
struggling a little bit
with like Tom, we've done
this, we've done that,
what are the results?
Why aren't they calling us yet
versus this patience, patience, patience?
- That is audacity.
That's ego.
I never think anything.
I think I suck.
I'm being dead serious.
I'm confident
but like I genuinely wake
up this morning and be like,
I could suck for the next year
and make a ton of bad decisions
and literally everything
I've done is wiped.
I believe that.
Business is unforgiving
compared to sports on this one.
In sports,
Muhammad Ali can lose to Trevor
Berbick in his last fight,
we don't know that.
I know that because I'm a boxing nerd.
You don't know that.
Business is different.
When you lose,
everyone then wipes out
what you've done well.
- [Female] Like Boeing.
- What's that?
- Yeah, you know what I mean?
- [Female] Yeah.
- Like the narrative
can change very quickly.
We shit on Woolworth's.
It was the dominant
retailer in this country
for 100 fucking years.
- But on that journey right,
so not just having the
audacity of expecting
why doesn't it happen faster
but there's got to be something to know
you're on the right track, right?
Is it just content?
- No, no, no, the market
speaks, your business.
I knew I was on the right track
'cause the first two years
when I was half pregnant on VaynerMedia,
we did three million in revenue
and the first year I ran it
we went from three to 14.
That was very obvious.
And 14 to 27, like business results.
- And that was all based on what?
Less clients, bigger fees?
Talk to me about that.
- There's a lot of things I'm good at
and the core thing I'm good at
is a mix of the followings,
I tend to sell something
that most people don't see at first.
It ends up being right a lot of times
which creates the back end.
But at the time, I'm
extremely good at selling
in the short term.
There was no brand.
Twitter, I had a lot of followers
so there was a little something.
But what I'm really good at
is wasting no time on
selling to the unsellable.
One of the reasons I'm
fascinated by franchise
to become a franchisor and
I'm like what would I do
is 'cause I would be incredible
at getting franchisees
for a couple reasons.
One I'm just,
a lot of entrepreneurs look up to me
so that would be good probably.
But after I filled the bucket,
it's like Empathy,
okay I've sold my two million
dollars worth of wine.
Now I've got another four million to sell.
Now it's work.
In that part,
I just don't fucking waste time.
I go to a new business pitch,
back to the same way I know
somebody I fucked up on,
I go to a new business pitch,
it's scheduled for an hour,
I sometimes bounce after 30
'cause I decide it's
over three minutes in.
I'm like she has no interest in me.
And I don't have ego to be like
to convince her.
I'll give it my best at bat
and hopefully he or she will like it
but I think the reason I
was able to grow so quickly
is I'm very good at selling
and focusing on people
that will actually buy.
- So get enough people interest
and then move on from the one and done?
- It's funny, I think,
back to like what you said,
I never think I deserve anything, period.
And look, VaynerMedia's the
only company run by somebody
who actually has success in
doing the work that they do.
Like in the whole fucking ad world,
like I laugh when people
think I'm Gary Vee
and don't realize I'm
running this company.
You're doing social media work
with an agency
that was built to make
television commercials?
I'm like the fucking poster
child of the whole game.
And yet we don't get business
from people all the time.
- Of course, of course.
You're only gonna get
certain batting averages,
it's gonna work out the way it does.
- But I think if you host a party,
if you create the right packaging
and then the right
merchandising of that packaging,
it's off to the races.
- How did you recruit early on?
What was the technique to get those,
to get the staff?
- I hired 50 kids
who had no idea what the
fuck they were doing.
- Just from where?
- You mean employees or?
- Yeah, employees.
At the time I had a big enough Twitter.
My brother brought like six of his friends
from high school and college.
It was a fucking rat,
we didn't have any agency people.
So at the level you're at now,
the content will recruit.
Run your podcast against
employees of your competitors
that you want to hire.
- We need to do a lot more paid.
- You have to do a lot more paid.
When organic, this is for everybody,
when organic went away from Facebook
and everybody got anger and
fuck Facebook, I got fucked,
I got pumped
because people started getting confused
because paid was underpriced
and I was like I'm unemotional.
If I can,
I get that this was free
but if this is still a good deal,
then it's still a good deal.
I don't care about yesterday,
back to that mentality.
Yesterday doesn't matter.
Facebook's free.
You got all that organic traffic.
You weren't paying Facebook
for that organic traffic,
it was a trade.
They had a platform
with a lot of attention,
you produced content for it
and a trade.
The organic goes down,
you have to pay for it,
you have to do a lot more paid.
The reason you have to do
a lot more paid, everybody,
is you can target who you want to reach.
When you know you're about to spend $150
against employees of
your direct competitor
from eight towns over,
you're already thinking differently
in the video you're about to make.
You might make a video
of how fun it is at your
foosball table in your office
'cause Rick at the other company's like
we don't have a foosball table.
I only make content
knowing whose gonna see it.
- And the answer is do it, right?
- People are always like
you always go about it,
I'm like I made a video called you're 65
and you're life's not over
and I ran ads against people who were 65.
It's gonna do well.
It's really,
people underestimate how powerful it is.
- Action's the key, execute something.
- But if you make the
podcast, you'll crush
because now you're
gonna have COOs and CFOs
come in and be guests,
that's gonna already be a
slight biz dev opportunity.
But you're also gonna
be able to post produce
and run some of those funny
quotes, funny moments.
She's gonna be looking,
you're gonna be thinking, oh,
Jason and I are doing it right now.
I'm like what I'm telling you
to do I'm doing right now.
As I'm talking I'm like
looking at him like
did you see that,
was that smart,
should we cut that,
let's test that?
That's what you'll be doing in a year.
And now all of a sudden,
you answer the question
where the CFO of the top 15 company
is really caught off guard
and she's like that's smart
and now you're like oh.
Now you're running it against all CFOs.
The machine.
- [Male] Just one question as a follow-up.
- Yep.
- [Male] So you always
talk about the content
and let the market decide.
- Yes.
- [Male] So but for you
when you launched Wine Library,
you said a year nobody watched it.
- Yes.
- [Male] So if we're producing content,
personal brand and other things,
you didn't let that swing you
but did the market eventually?
- Because I have no
expectations of the market
for a long time.
- [Male] For the wine
versus the motivation in business mindset
that seems to be driving different,
do you think the wine content
of would do well right now
if you would relaunch it?
- I think I'm a showman in hindsight.
Something I didn't know
about myself at 34,
I really didn't.
I got a D in speech.
I didn't know that I had this schtick.
I knew I was a good salesman
on the floor at the liquor store,
I knew that I was good class clown
where the teacher wasn't mad at me
so I knew I had a good tact
but none of this stuff
even crossed my mind.
So I think if I did anything
tomorrow it would work, really,
if I talked about something I knew.
If I did a sports show,
I would be the number,
I genuinely believe
I'd be the number one
voice in sports today
if I decided tomorrow
for the next three years to go all in,
I think I'd be bigger than Steven A. Smith
and Max Kellerman
and all these, I just do,
'cause I think I have a personality
that clicks with people.
That's just a trait.
Some people don't.
That's why I talk about writing and audio.
You might not be great on video
but you may be a tremendous writer
or you might just not be cracked up
to be the personality
than you lean into the
logo or hire somebody.
MetLife hired Snoopy.
- You have a piece of content
where you talked about how
you do this thing at Vayner
where you like invested,
investment year, profit year--
- Oh, the stairs.
You know, I think I'm uncomfortable
with not having some cash
on hand for a rainy day.
So I used to think a lot,
now I've molded a little bit from it
but I'm a very big fan of getting people
to invest in your business
instead of taking the money off the table.
Just everybody wants
to built big businesses
but then what they're really doing
is building lifestyle businesses
for the things they want
which is also tough for me
because if you want a car,
kudos, do your thing,
but yeah, I aggressively in
the first five years of Vayner
and the first five years of Wine Library,
had a pretty hardcore system
where one year I would
try to make no profit,
pour all of it, all of it, zero.
- And the following year?
- A little bit more.
- Which is like five?
Like give it to me.
- I'll give it to you.
For both businesses,
between five and 10%.
- Is that where you run it today,
keep running it the same way,
you've changed that?
- I keep running it 'cause I'm just like,
but again I'm building it in perpetuity.
You have to know what you're up to.
Again, if somebody here
wants to flip their business,
and I'm sure everybody's
a big boy and big girl
enough to know that
but yeah, look it's your
other family member,
you got to feed it,
you got to take care of it.
- Cool.
- If you want to build big.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, which is the goal.
- Well then you got to feed it.
And then that's when you can
hire and fire, all that stuff,
'cause you're not worried about the,
people are like well Gary, it
costs more to fire somebody.
Well I'm not as worried
about the profit margin
being insane.
I'm trying to catch the growth.
(upbeat music)